Look at my genetic testing. Are those genetic defects permanent? So the answer is yes. So another
question that would follow up on that is, should I ever run my genetics again? Well for most people,
the answer would be no. Because those genetic defects are not going to improve. Now, I remember
when the genetic testing first came out years ago, we were really one of the first clinics to
implement it. I used to do genetic testing for gosh, just, you know, maybe even a dozen people
a week. So we've done a lot of this. I've probably looked at more genetics than people most
practitioners. It doesn't mean I know more than most practitioners. It just means I've looked at a lot
of people's genes. And there were those, there were practitioners at that time when genetic testing
first came out saying that oh, you can change your person's genes and making all these, these,
these promises that if you're taking this nutrient, you can change a person's genes and all this
stuff coming out. It's like, oh yeah, well just it's easy to prove that comment by just running a
person's genetics again. It's never been done. So yes, if you're going to have, if you have a genetic
defect, if you have a single allele or a double allele defect on a specific gene, it's never going to get
better. The thing that can change though is that it could get worse. So if how, so the reason why you
have genetic defects are two reasons. You can have genetic defects because you inherited them from your
parents. 99.9% of your genetic defects, you inherited from your parents. The second way you can get
a genetic defect is what's called an acquired defect. And that is, you know, a toxin, you're exposed
to some sort of oxidizing agent that damages your genes. That's the whole thing about this,
this COVID vaccine and the COVID disease is that it could be gene-altering. When you're taking an
mRNA vaccine, which is just about all the vaccines, our mRNA vaccines now, it can alter your genes.
That's not a good thing. You alter your genes either through a toxin or a vaccine. Now you're
going to pass down that altered gene to your offspring. Well, it's okay. It's not a big deal,
because I'm in my 60s and I'm not having any more kids. Well, we don't know what it's doing to
you health wise and your defense against other disorders, you know, in the years that you have left.
But worse, they're been vaccinated to children with mRNA vaccines that are going to alter their
genes that they're going to pass down to their children. We're actually ruining our species,
we're damaging our entire species. You know, what's honest is I've looked at so many people's genetic
profiles, that the people that have the best genetic profiles, meaning the least defects, are the
older people. So typically, the older you are, you think, well, how's that? If you're acquiring
defects by exposure to toxins, not all toxins that are going to damage your genes. So it is,
it is though, the older people that were probably, you think, well, the older people, they were
exposed to more toxins that they're like, no, for the first maybe 30 or 40 years of their life,
they're exposed to a lot fewer toxins. We're exposed to a lot more toxins today
that our ancestors were, our great-grandparents probably had very few genetic defects.
And the exposure of environmental toxins over the years increased the amount of acquired
defects that then were handed down to children. So when I look at somebody's genes from, say,
75-year-old or an 85-year-old patient, it's like, oh my gosh, this is the way it was supposed to be.
And you look at somebody's genes from a 23-year-old patient, it's like, oh my word, it's like so many
defects. So long answer to the question, you're not going to improve those defects and acquired
genetic defect damage. It's going to cause defects that then will be also permanent and be handed down
to the next generation.